Hello. I'm the nostalgia critic. I remember it. So [you] don't have to and welcome to another edition of old versus new
This is where I take something old and nostalgic and compare it to a recent remake with that
So let's take a look at what are the rings?
Becoming the holy Bible of Geekdom Lord of the rings by jrr
Tolkien has revolutionized the style of fantasy and given a whole new respect to the Genre
Many of us know about the Peter Jackson movies based on the books that came out between 2001 2003
But there was another version that came out in the 70s that a lot of people don't know about this was rubbish geese, Lord
Well consider both the critical and box-office disappointment. [bash]. Be slower rings offered a very different
Take on the classic story and has since then either been loved by fans or [-] tested by them
But isn't anything compared to the big-budget
Extravaganza of the Jackson movies now, technically speaking, this is all opinion based
But I have an online show which automatically means that my opinion is better than yours
Nananana, so let's take a look at Ralph's Bash [G] and Peter Jackson's
Now see how the [ralph] [Bakshi] film ends at the exact same point that the pierre Jackson film the two towers ends
I decided to include the two towers in this comparison as was the fellowship of the ring
But that said let's take a look at our main character frodo baggins
One of the things I love about the Jackson lore the rings movies is the casting
Everybody in these movies looks the part and I heard Elijah wood was going to play frodo
I thought it was the best casting since Keanu reeves played that mentally retarded boy and Bill [&] Ted's Excellent adventure
[I] am an adventure turned out to be quite different
He was kind innocent and extremely bold
But maybe a little too vulnerable in the basket version photo is just [as] wide-eyed and curious
But he does fight back and can also stand up for [himself] not true
They [most] save Sam from gollum but the [basking] one seems to be a little tougher and in control I would put you down on
Command you to leap off a cliff or into a fire
and you
Would do its makeup [like] here's what the black riders trying to attack
Fertile actually gets out his sword and does try to fight in the Jackson one. He just drops it
If you could Kindly stab yourself with that
I'd be most thankful or how about another encounter with the black riders even though he's sick and can barely stay awake
He actually manages to make his way past the river and even intimidate [though]. Sorry
Sorry
By all the shire you shall have neither the ring nor
[made] the Jackson one just sort of passes out and let someone else carry him off
by the way
How does that work if the sword wound works its way to his heart he becomes one of the black writers?
Would I have you would have become like them one of the ring wraiths?
Wouldn't that [be] a little um?
Awkward I mean, I don't think they look as a timid ad if a little guy in a cloak is running around
Yeah, maybe they just give him a desk job. I do eight Mondays
Even though I love Elijah wood is frodo the basking one
Just seemed a little stronger as well as closer to the book
No offense would the point goes to becky what do you know about it?
nothing
but what about the supporting cast [the] little people who make it possible for the
Other little people there's a lot to get through so let's take a gander
Now this one's really hard because the rest of the cast is sort of hit and miss
Sam in the Jackson film for example as a tough royal friend who will stick with Mr.
Frodo through thick and thin don't you leave him Samwise Gamgee can I don't mean to while Sam and the Baskerville is
Not I mean good. God. What did they do to you Sam? [I]?
[really] don't know what went wrong with this character, but they fucked up when
Mr.. Brogan Mr.. Frodo. He's Gone
He's sick, and he needs a rest help a dragon, and I want my bottle someone give me my bottle
shot
Which is funny because merry and pippin are at the opposite ends of the spectrum as well in the [Jackson] film
They're a little overplay making them a tad too. Goofy, but still all around my thing that works good
Let's get another one at where the bashed evil
They're actually under played seeming a little bit more like real-life people
But to be honest not leaving much of an impression you cannot trust us to let you face trouble alone
And go up without a word. We're your friends frodo. Well. Thank you pippin. I'm [mary]. Whatever you're all short
[gandalf] is good both versions [breeding] this strong mythical element while also mixing in the side effects of his age
this last journey must be for others to make ah
And who are they to be that is what they're trying to decide here my problem is in the bash B film
He's a little too over-the-top. I compare these two scenes where he yells in heaven fool of a
[threw] yourself in [next] time and rid us of your stupidity fool of a duck so yourself in next time fool
What?
What oh?
oh, oh
[but] one of the biggest differences is aragorn. Which is totally blown away by the bash B film now granted
I'm not quite sure why it looks like a native American that certainly wasn't the sign of the book
But the character is still a million times better
Why?
Well being voiced by John heard one of the greatest actors of all time certainly helps my name is aragorn Son of arathorn
[but] on top of that the idea behind ever going to safety was both a ranger and a king
With the Jackson version you certainly buy the ranger part, but I never really saw anything kingly in it decide the ranger
become who you were born to be by
killing things and slaughtering evildoers
Just do a very kingly the best people [ones] seem to pull off both
He could be a badass, but he could also be very smooth and diplomatic
[Lothlorien] has a place of healing
There is no evil in it and unless a man brings evil bear with him on top of that he could also be very intimidating
Because if I wanted the ring for myself, I could have it
now
Please don't kill me
The Jackson will never seem to have that confidence or inner strength that the other one had
And the only [king] we think ever did was make a motivational speech. [I] see in your [eyes] the
Same fear that would take the heart of me
[okay], may come when the courage of men fails, but it is not this day this day we fight
I mean who the hell could possibly get a role of leadership?
By having no political background and just making a bunch of pretty speech, okay fine
But you gotta give them credit they both have totally different
ways of dealing with their problems for example when a horrible threat comes across king aragorn
He fails them out with billions of dollars and hopes they know how to spend it wisely but gene
For Aragorn's weaknesses though Jackson Phil makes up for it with the addition of gollum which has done much better at Jackson's version again
The [baby] one isn't bad. They certainly have the addiction down in the hinting towards madness. Oh, yeah
Yes, it lays nice, [obit], but the Jackson one really took the character to a whole new level
He was devious, but sympathetic when bad things happened to him [you've] [got] genuinely sorry like [to] [us] always
Plus they really play [around] the split personality bit
I
Love come back
Come back
[I'll] be right back coca-cola. [yeah], we want original classic
Calories, we're trying to [miss] right no relax [right], [sweetie]
[just] [suck] you suck
There's of course a ton of other characters, but they're all kind of on the same level
They're good, but not great each having their strengths and weaknesses
tough cold
I'm gonna go with the Jackson one mostly because they have more time in two movies to Flesh their characters out
And that's a huge advantage. Sorry gandalf. We still love you
What?
Euros don't mean crap unless you have some good villains to go up against and these movies had plenty
Again from a casting point of view you could have got a better pick than Christopher lee for sorrows
He look the part acted [the] part
But most of all he sounded the part [Sarang's] forces are already moving the nine have left Mina's morgul
God there. Is that voice cool. It did not seriously take there's an object of contend with a will of soda
[I] think it's another one of those voices you don't want reading bedtime stories to your kids
Though once upon a time there were three bears
three innocent sweet [oh]
suspecting Bears
[I]
Wonder the bass you film is okay, but you don't see much [about] where is the ring gandalf?
Why'd you rather see the [dark] Lord have it? [oh]?
No
[please] don't flash me
Something I never understood in the banshee film though is for some reason [they] stopped pronouncing the s and simply calm our maps
Why is the s suddenly a bad word only because our bond is kind it should have been his friend our man how long since?
[Harriman] a double-Barrel an auto man
it is
Pronounced Saruman Dance isn't Silent also
How come gandalf can never figure out [the] [Sorrow] Mom's Gonna be a bad guy?
I mean do these look like the homes of any decent people
You know your love of the halflings leaf has clearly slowed your mind. [oh] stop hushing my buzz
Flick [writers] are all hard to decide between two. I mean the Jacksonville odds were cool. Especially how you never see their faces
But the baggy ones were also pretty
Intimidating ranging from fragile creepy folk to tough soldiers of Darkness almost as if their power feared in and out at times
[so] again, they do go a bit over the top end moments
Give the Tyler though
also, the Jackson version
I thought the way they looked we put the ring on was a little goofy if I didn't ever like the way things [look] we
Put the ring on it's like a third grader went nuts with the smudge to our photoshop
In the basket fell they don't really change, but you can tell you've entered a different world everything's slower the color changes
it's almost like a different state of being but
[for] me the big deciding [point] is the lord of darkness itself Sauron and believe it or not
I actually like the [basti] one better
Simply because you never see him the most we get is a guy in a viking hat which isn't very intimidating
But everything else is kept a mystery. You never see him
but you can always feel his presence simply by the way people talk about him under the power of Sauron [the] dark lord of
Mordor look at the scene with the eye in the fountain you came to tell that it is an eye
But the fear that fills everybody is still present do not touch the water
He's looking for you. The door is closed
If your quest fails, then nothing can stand against him and we are defenseless
Now let's look at the Jacksonville
It's just too overblown the item looks more like a lizard side which indicates on is more of a monster than he is a man
Even his costume seems over-the-top. There's just nothing subtle about it when I think of the lord of darkness
I think of something sneaky conniving and quiet not loud bombastic and in-your-face
Let me saw Sauron as a plotter someone who's waiting to strike in the shadows where this guy seems like the Hulk's metal pincushion
oh sword mean
Sauron have explosive diarrhea
sarang go boom
So like I said before [tough] call
But seeing how less is usually more I have to go into Baskerville because let's face it
No one can bring the dread and feelings of doom than the guy who directed cool world, [huh]?
Point goes to Becky oh
Well, that's all fine and good, but how can they beat the shit out of each other? Here's the best actions
Now [both] [these] stones are unique
and how they do their actions
Jackson's movies are a little bit more acrobatic and inventive where bosch needs is a little bit more gritty and bloody
it's interesting to how the Jackson films do the battle of helm's deep in all blue and the Bosch key film does the battle and
[on] red. I don't even know why it turns all red just looks really cool
In another flip-flop where the [Baski] felt have little build up
But a lot of [payoff] the Jackson film has a lot of build up, but little payoff
What do I mean by this well in the batch conversion? There's a real feeling of suspense in tension?
I mean when someone gets dead you really felt like you're getting stabbed in
The Jackson one they tempt death just a few too many times
I mean they literally jump into the middle of an army of Orcs not once not twice, but [three] times
And not [once] do they ever get a scratch on them
Because I shouldn't defend the bench you film too much though. I mean look when they fire the arrows the numb nuts. Don't even move
I'm far too proud to be searching for color. I like this place to be good drunk here
Good, right
and we won't be taking the listed advantage of
[magic] for [an] event now of course the return to king [is] some of the best action scenes ever but since - he never made
It that far. I really don't count it. But still the action in the Jackson films really are better
They're more flashy more creative and more energized
I would like to seen a little bit more grisly and realistic
But then again it is a fancy, so I guess anything goes point goes to [Jason] then you know nothing
So once again it comes down to story which one had a better plot the better painting and the better delivery
Let's take story front [away]
It is interesting how both vashti and Jackson [enter] films at the exact same point
They when the battle of helm's deep [and] [gollum] lead Sam and frodo does she lobe even though when the ball comes deep is in
The middle and they already met up wish you look
great
[she] my pilk
Mm-Hmm and again the Jacksonville has the advantage that has two films to explain the story and where - he only has one
Because of this the bash [key] film suffers characters can't be fleshed out like they should and some characters just disappear altogether
Our wind ever makes an appearance in a one, I don't even think ever gets a line. She just stands there my
Sister [daughter] [ailing] my only loyal kin since her brother has disobeyed my commands
Unfortunately, she's a mute
But the Jackson [felmy] time seems a bit rushed - like I never did enjoy the editing of the first film
It seemed way too fragmented not the shires been invited Roberta. He's up to something
Alright, then keep your secrets. [I] like talking in sentences without any pauses don't you yes I do. I like it a lot indeed, huh?
Antibodies credit for all the scenes he had to cut the scenes
It does keep in are often very quiet and usually allow for a lot [of] atmosphere
Which I think in a lot of ways is closer to the books
Take for example when Gimli finds out two wars in the mines of [Moria] have all been destroyed. Here's the Jackson version
oh
[Eli's] body oh
Suze I feared [oh]
oh
Now here's the Master version
yesterday
Balin Lord of Moria fell an
Orc shot him from behind a stone. He doesn't scream. He doesn't yell he just slowly walks away to [be] by himself
It's a lot more powerful
but to be fair
Jackson's film has a lot of powerful scenes too many of which were not [even] focused on that much in the book like our ones
Debate about choosing immortal life. It's really looked into and analyzed you will linger on and
darkness and in doubt
There's even a few subtle scenes as well like in the [bashed] you film frodo makes a big speech about how they probably never get
Back I reckon we got enough left to [seize] to this mount doom
After that you I dunno oh sad friend of friends
After that if the ring goes into the fire and we're at hand after that dear Sam
just to get there just
To get there yet in the Jackson film is literally just sewed off in a walk you go ahead and eat them. I've rationed it
there should [be] enough for
What?
the Journey home
That look alone used to say everything
and as the films went on they did get progressively better it better taking their time with the story and not feeling as rushed as
Before so while I have to admit, it's not really a close call
There are a lot of elements in the banshee film that are not only subtle, but really work well
It's a lot of over-the-top moments sure and some scenes
Don't really make sense, but what they do get right they get really right, so even though
This is probably a surprise to no one the film that really is better is the Peter Jackson version the superior?
So there you go Peter Jackson Vs.. Ralph Becky I
Do feel bad, I'm not able to compare return the king to anything. oh wait a minute [the] rack and bass version. That's right
They did return the king well. I'll just compare those two that
I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to